the battle for control of Southern and
Eastern Ukraine is intensifying this
morning Ukraine's Army is moving to cut
off Russian forces in the key city of
her son hoping to build on other
successes on the battlefield Russian
President Vladimir Putin has now
declared martial law in four provinces
that were illegally annexed earlier this
month Holly Williams is in Kiev
Ukraine's Capital Holly good morning
good morning Vladimir Putin's
announcement of Martial law could be
another sign that his invading Army is
running into serious problems
in her son one of the regions occupied
by Russia the authorities installed by
Moscow have started moving tens of
thousands of people away from the front
line ahead of an expected Ukrainian
counter-offensive and
troops back about to hold on to land
they've seized the mood on Russian State
tv seems close to despair
don't expect any good news in the next
two months says this correspondent the
anchorwoman asks why Russia thought
President Vladimir zielinski would run
away and NATO wouldn't help she doesn't
say it but those are really questions
for Vladimir Putin the man who started
this war
President Biden said yesterday the
Russian leaders in a quote incredibly
difficult position it seems his only
tool available to him
is to brutalize individual citizens
he's doing that with swarms of so-called
suicide drones targeting Ukraine cities
and attacks on the power grid as a harsh
winter Looms
but ukrainians as always have responded
with stunning resilience
key of Subway has served as a bomb
shelter for civilians during Russian
attacks but this morning we found it
packed with busy commuters apparently
determined to live their lives as normal
in the face of a vicious Invasion but I
think we'll go through it and we will
win soon we believe in it and also
surrendering is not in our DNA Andre
zagarodnuk is Ukraine's former Minister
of Defense these so-called suicide
drones they seem like a very conscious
attempt to terrorize the civilian
population is it going to work very
simple answer no yes they will damage
some infrastructure that's for sure are
they going to terrorize civilians which
are then change their mind about the
course of the war absolutely not
power outages of up to four hours are
expected across Ukraine today the
national Energy company has urged people
to ensure that they have warm socks
blankets and hugs from family and
friends Gail
Holly Williams reporting from Ukraine we
thank you